do you think you got what it takes
well.alright Joran welcome aboard
[Music]
the idea for the film came from when I
directed Monsters Inc at the end of the
day would crawl under my desk and just
puddle up into a ball and I had a lot of
daydreams of just floating away and so
this idea of a house floating into the
sky with balloons coupled with the
appeal and fun that I thought we could
have with a grouchy old man that's where
the film started and then we asked
herself why is he floating away where is
he going why couldn't he just take the
train and that's what led us to a story
of a promise to his wife that was
unfulfilled and the reason for his
journey that sequence started fully
scripted we wrote multiple short little
scenes the first draft we introduced to
the characters in a battle Carl was
trying to catch a bird and Ellie came to
the birds defense and punched him so now
Carl was out for revenge
so it became a back and forth punching
contest in the most unlikely places he
thought it was hilarious but we showed
it to the audience and they just kind of
went over like a red balloon
sar had a story on the film came to me
and said I think this would work better
with no dialogue and I said no I think
you're wrong but he eventually talked me
into it
my crockpot theory is I grew up watching
super 8 film that my parents had taken
there's something about stripping away
some elements that makes it more
emotional having something lacking makes
the audience an active participant and
maybe this is why older filmmakers boned
the loss of the silent films there's one
moment in that montage where Ellie has
to go to the doctor and it's implied
that they can't have children and that
raised some eyebrows as we were
developing the film so we did experiment
with taking it out but the strange thing
was not only did we not feel the emotion
as strongly in that one little scene but
the whole film lost a little bit and I
can't really fully explain that other
than to say it was a real dark low a
moment for them that made that
relationship feel more real the pain and
loss of that situation bonded those
characters together and made you
emphasize more for them when we go out
into the world and screen it I sit over
to the side and I sneak peeks at the
audience that we're only 710 minutes
to the film and people are wiping my
tears and really involved and I thought
okay I feel like we're on to something
here
when we start out making these films
we're just trying to make something
funny and entertaining and hopefully it
with a bit of heart and emotion to it
but they sometimes tap into people's own
lives in ways that are completely
unexpected this is a bunch of pixels on
the screen and none of it actually
exists so that's part of what I really
love about making animated films is we
can really make the audience care about
these characters as though they're real
people these films in a way are rest her
CIL's for Lyford a lot of people when
kids play house or cars they're kind of
acting out and trying this suit on and I
think films are a little bit of the same
way it's a way of understanding the
world and that's what we're striving to
do with animation is to take all the
messiness of life and make it more pure
and easy to understand
[Music]